GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME HEAR
ME. DRIVING ON. YOU'RE OPEN TO
THE PHONE YES.
SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON WE DO
HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES TODAY. BEFORE
WITNESSES AND TESTIMONY TO.
TODAY AND ROOM FORTY TWO OH TWO
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICAL
DISTANCE AND THE PERSON HEARING
IN THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE ELEVEN MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO
WILL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR
THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE
THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY IN A HEARING. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN MAKE EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. WE WILL ALSO
USE A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SYSTEM THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. BASED ON WHETHER
YOUR SUPPORT FOR OP. OP
OPPOSING A BILL. ARE CALLING
IN. PLEASE ESTIMATE ALL PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MEETING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL. YOU REMAIN
ON THE LIVE LINE AND WILL NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY COMES WITH A
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT AND MY STUFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP YOU. I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSSESS POSITION
LET OUR PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE ALL IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ARE ALL FACING. NOW
BEFORE WE TAKE UP OUR BILLS AND
LIKE TO GO OVER A FEW
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO
FILL IN FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK FOR TODAY'S HEARING RISKS
WE ARE SORRY DOCTOR CAN'T BE
HERE WITH US TODAY BUT WE ARE
HAPPY TO WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MELINDA'S HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILL TELL IS FILLING
THAT VACANCY FOR THIS HEARING
ONLY. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SPECIFICALLY
ARE CONSENT CALENDAR COMPRISES
OF FILE ITEM SEVEN. AB THIRTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO. AND FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY THREE. WE WILL TAKE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TO PROBABLY WOULD PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OR WITH
CONCERNS. THESE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY. ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. WE WILL BE
HEARING BILLS IN ORDER SHOWN ON
OUR AGENDA. FINALLY A BRIEF
WORD ABOUT THE LIMITED NUMBER
OF BILLS WE ARE TAKING OUT. AS
CHAIR MY POLICY HAS BEEN TO
PROCURE EVERY BILL ABSENT OF
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES
OBVIOUSLY IT COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS CHANGED EVERYTHING.
MOST OF THE BILLS WE HEAR
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY IMPACT THE
STATE AND LOCAL REVENUES AND IT
IS MY RESPONSIBILITY TO CHART A
PRUDENT COURSE WELL CALIFORNIA
CASES THE TWIN CHALLENGES OF
THE PANDEMIC AND IT'S ECONOMIC
FALLOUT. PUT SIMPLY ANY BILL
THAT REDUCES GENERAL FUND
REVENUE WAS THOROUGHLY
SCRUTINIZED AND MOST WERE NOT
SET FOR HEARING. THIS WAS
DECISION WAS NOT MADE LIGHTLY
IT WAS MADE TO REFLECT THE
REALITY WE CURRENT FIND
OURSELVES IN. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. MR ROUGHLY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BURKE
HERE BURKE HERE BRO. BRO HERE
TO. CHIU HERE GREAT LEVINE
MAYES MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HERE GLORIA
THREE OF US I WAS HERE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HERE MADAM CHAIR YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU- AND
BEFORE WE CAR FIRST WHEN AS A
DO YOU WANT TO SAY WE'RE SORRY
AGAIN I WANT TO SAY WE'RE SORRY
THE DOCTOR QUIRK WAS NOT ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
TODAY WE HAVE EXTENDED HIM THE
OFFER OF PROVIDE. ANY SORT OF
TESTIMONY OR ANY SORT OF
QUESTIONS THAT HE HAS ON BILLS
TO IN ADVANCE- BECAUSE HIS
INPUT IT'S ALWAYS BEEN VERY
VALUED IN COMMITTEE SO. WITH
THAT LET'S START WITH FILE ITEM
ONE AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
DOCTOR RANDY LOW YOUR FREEDOM
OPEN WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ON AB
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
REGARDING COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKS
COMMUNITY BLOOD BANKING IS ONE
OF THE BEHIND THE SCENES
PILLARS OF FIRST RESPONSE YET
IN CALIFORNIA IN STATE BLOOD
DONOR TESTING FOR LABORATORY
ASSETS HAVE CLIMBED OVER THE
LAST TWO DECADES. CALIFORNIA IS
THE ONLY STATE THAT IMPOSES
STATE SALES TAX ON BLOOD DONOR
TESTING REAGENTS EQUIPMENT AND
SUPPLIES. ONLY TWO DONOR
TESTING LABORATORIES REMAIN
OPERATIONAL IN THE STATE THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTER
WHICH IS AN FRESNO IN THE
STANFORD BLOOD CENTER IN PALO
ALTO. ALL OTHER BLOOD BANKS NOW
SEND THEIR SAMPLES TO OUT OF
STATE LABORATORIES FOR TESTING
PARTLY DUE TO THE INCREASE OF
IN STATE COSTS WITH SALES TAX.
THE REDUCED NUMBER OF BLOOD
TESTING FACILITIES WITHIN THE
STATE RAISES PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS AND PRESENTS A CRISIS
IN THE EVENT OF A MAJOR
HOMELAND SECURITY OR MASS
CASUALTY OF AND- AS WE NOW KNOW
ALL TOO WELL. BLOOD BANK ACROSS
THE STATE ARE EXPERIENCING
CRITICAL NEEDS DURING THE COVE
AT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. MORE THAN
FLICK FIFTY BLOOD DRIVES HAVE
BEEN CANCELED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA LEADING TO A SEVERE
SHORTAGE AND BLOOD. THE LACK OF
ADEQUATE FACILITIES TO SCREEN
BLOOD DONATIONS MAKES THE
PUBLIC VULNERABLE TO THE BLOOD
PRODUCT AVAILABILITY. WITH THE
ONLY TWO DONOR TESTING LABS
FUNCTIONING IN THE STATE THERE
IS A SERIOUS CONCERN FOR
DELAYED ACCESS TO NEEDED BLOOD
SUPPLIES FOR TRANSFUSIONS AND
TRANSFERRING BLOOD SUPPLIES
ACROSS STATE LINES. AB TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE EXEMPTS SALES
AND USE TAX ON LABORATORY
EQUIPMENT AND CHEMICAL REAGENTS
USED BY A LICENSED BLOOD BANK
TO TEST VOLUNTARILY DONATED
HUMAN BLOOD. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
EXEMPT EQUIPMENT CHEMICALS AND
REAGENTS AND QUALITY CONTROL
AND MATERIALS THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRED TO
PERFORM FTA AND CALIFORNIA
MANDATED SCREENING TESTS. TO
ASSURE THE SAFETY OF
VOLUNTARILY BLOOD PLATELETS AND
PLASMA DONATIONS FOR
TRANSFUSION. THE EXEMPTIONS
WILL PROVIDE VITAL COST RELIEF
TO THE REMAINING TWO CENTERS
THAT PERFORM IN STATE DONOR
TESTING ON BLOOD DONATIONS
HELPING THESE LABS TO REMAIN
VIABLE. THIS EXEMPTION MAY ALSO
ENCOURAGE OTHER CALIFORNIA
BLOOD CENTERS TO RESUME BLOOD
DONOR TESTING IN OUR STATE.
BLOOD CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT COLLECT BLOOD FOR
TRANSFUSIONS ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS ANY COST RELIEF
FROM THE EXEMPTION WOULD
BENEFIT PUBLIC HEALTH AND WOULD
HELP TO CONTAIN COSTS. HERE TO
TESTIFY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
THIS CHRISTOPHER STOP WITH THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTER
AS WELL AS HER PRETE SEND DO
WITH THE STANFORD BLOOD CENTER.
THE WE HAVE A MOTION BY A BRO A
SECOND BY PETRIE-NORRIS. I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES I WOULD ASK A
MODERATOR TO CONNECT THIS FIRST
WITH MR STOP. STOP YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER
STOP ON THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD
CENTER IN FRESNO AND I SUPPORT
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE.
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTER
HAS MAINTAINED AN UPGRADED ITS
HIGH COMPLEXITY BLOOD DONOR
TESTING LABORATORY THROUGH SIX
DECADES SERVING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY COMMUNITIES ON BLOOD
CENTERS AROUND THE STATE AND
NATION. WE EMPLOY ABOUT EIGHT
LABORATORY SCIENCES AS WELL
IT'S ABOUT TWELVE LABORATORY
TECHNICIAN. HAVING OUR LAB IN
HOUSE HELPS US MAINTAIN RAPID
ACCESS TO DONATED BLOOD MARCH
FOR OUR HOSPITALS HAVING OUR
LABORATORY HAS ENABLED US TO
RESPOND RAPIDLY WELL THE FDA
REQUESTED THAT WE PRODUCE
PROBATE NINETEEN CONVALESCENT
PLASMA. AND WE BECAME THE FIRST
BLOOD CENTER IN THE NATION THE
PRODUCE PATHOGEN INACTIVATED
WHOLE BIT CONVALESCENT PLASMA
TO BRING HOPE TO PATIENTS WITH
COPD AT NINETEEN THE PANDEMIC
HAS STRAPS THE BOTTOM LINE OF A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION. I'D
LIKE TO COMMENT. S. IS RATED
WHETHER THE- EXAM SUPPLIES
EQUIPMENT AND REAGENTS COULD BE
USED FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
WHETHER THE SCOPE OF THE
EXTENSIONS COULD BE
INADVERTENTLY TO BROUGHT THE
ANSWER IS NO THE FDA
REGULATIONS ON BLOOD DONOR
SCREENING ARE VERY SPECIFIC
REGION EQUIPMENT USED FOR
SCREENING BLOOD DONATIONS ARE
SPECIFICALLY LICENSED BY THE
FDA SOLELY FOR THIS PURPOSE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY THE
NARROW SCOPE OF THE ITEMS BEING
EXEMPTED BECAUSE WHEN. IF
UNDERSTOOD IT EXPLAIN GUIDE TO
LEAVE THE DISPARITY BETWEEN OUR
ESTIMATES OF REVENUE LOSS TO
THE STATE OF BETWEEN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND A
YEAR. AND A HIGHER LAUNCH TO
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
ASSESSMENT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS IMPORTANT
BILL WHICH WOULD CERTAINLY HELP
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD BY
EXEMPTING THESE VERY SPECIFIC
ITEMS FROM SALES AND USE TAX IN
CALIFORNIA. JUST OF THE OTHER
BLOOD DONOR TESTING LAMPS APTED
DID MANAGE IN OTHER STATES OF
OUR NATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IF THE MODERATOR
WOULD NOW CONNECT US TO- MR
STAND DO. THERE'S A CENTER YOUR
LINES OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HER PRETENSE
YOU AND I AM THE CEO AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT STANFORD
BLOOD CENTER I SUPPORT.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE. GET THE BLOOD CENTER HAVE
MAINTAINED A HIGHLY SKILLED
DONOR INFECTIOUS DISEASE
TESTING LABORATORY SINCE THE
BLOOD CENTERS BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. OUR
DONOR TESTING LABORATORY
OPERATION ALLOWS US TO KEEP
JOBS IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY FOR
BOTH LICENSE FLAP PROFESSIONAL
AS WELL AS ON THAT YOUR JOB
TRAINED EMPLOYEES WHO SUPPORT
LAB OPERATION. OUR DONOR
TESTING LABORATORY OPERATIONS
ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE THE FDA
MANDATED TESTING DAY IN AND DAY
OUT. TO ENSURE TIMELY AN
ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF LIFESAVING
BLOOD PRODUCTS IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY WITHOUT HAVING TO
FACE THE RISK ASSOCIATED WITH
OUTSOURCING THIS TESTING.
INCLUDING INCLEMENT WEATHER
LOFT SAMPLE AIRLINE DELAYS
WHICH AFFECT THE AVAILABILITY
OF THESE LIFESAVING BLOOD
PRODUCT. IN ADDITION TO PORTING
THE ROUTINE OPERATION DURING
TIMES OF VERY DIFFICULT HEALTH
CHALLENGES IN OUR COMMUNITY
INCLUDING THE AIDS EPIDEMIC AND
THE CURRENT CO THE NINETEEN
GLOBAL ABBOTT PANDEMIC. OUR LAB
ALLOWS US TO RESPOND QUICKLY TO
THE NEEDS OF PATIENTS AND TO
THE SCIENTIFIC DATA AND
EARNINGS BY PREVENTING LOWER TO
RELEVANT CASTING BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND A
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL TO DO SO.
FOR EXAMPLE WE ARE THE FIRST
AND ONLY BLOOD CENTER IN NORTH
AMERICA TO PERFORM HARD COLD
BEACH NEW QUAKE AFTER. UNTIL
BUT THE STAMP ONE TENER AND THE
TEN CAL BY CENTER. DONOR
TESTING LAB OUR STATE HAS THE
ABILITY TO TAP AND WILL BE ONE
PRODUCT IN THE TIMES OF
DISASTER YOU THAT. SUCH AS
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
ONE WHEN GROUND AND AIR TRAVEL
WAS EXTREMELY LET DISTRICT AT.
WHILE OUR OUR LABS ARE NOT
BUILT FOR LARGE VOLUME. OKAY
HANDLE THE TESTING ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THESE
TIMES TO ALLOW THE MOST
CRITICAL BLOOD PRODUCT TO BE
TESTED LEAST. FOR THE MOST
CRITICAL PATIENTS TO ENSURE
THERE IS NOT COMPROMISED. AFTER
THE AFTER ANNUAL FOR STANFORD
CENTER ARE. TWO AND FIFTY
DOLLAR AND- IF THIS EXEMPTION
MAY BE A CREDIT AND THIS IS
SIMILAR TO THE ESTIMATED
SAVINGS CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
BLOOD CENTER. SO TOTAL IMPACT
OF APPROXIMATELY. FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE STATE.
THIS WOULD ALLOW US TO HAVE
SOME PARITY WITH THE TESTING
LAB IN OTHER STATES. AS WELL AS
OTHER CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTERS
WHO NOW SEND THEIR TESTING OUT
OF STATE AND ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
THE EXTENT. WITH THE HELP OF
THIS EXEMPTION DESCRIBED IN THE
FELT CAMPER BLOOD CENTER
INTENDS TO KEEP OUR DONOR
TESTING LAB AS AN INTEGRAL PART
OF OPERATION. FOR THE GOOD OF
OUR PATIENTS OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA A LARGE. TO PROVIDE
THIS CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICE IN THE EVENT AN
UNPLANNED DISASTER AND- MAP
CASUALTY AMOUNT. I FOR YOUR%
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I
APOLOGIZE MISS AND DO. NOT
AFTER THAT IF THE MODERATOR NOW
OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTING TESTIMONY.
IF YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE AN OPERATOR WILL.
ANSWER YOUR LINE. IN YOUR
COMMENT WILL BE TAKEN IN ORDER
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A COMMENT
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. OR GO TO
LINE TWENTY SIX TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY SIX THIRTY
YOU IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU.
HELLO THIS IS FRED KNOW WHERE
REPRESENTING SCAMPERED
HEALTHCARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE. IF
THEIR ARGUMENT PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. FURTHER
PHONE LINES IN Q. WE HAVE ONE
WITNESS IN THE IN THE ROOM HE
FEEL FREE TO GET TO MOVE TO THE
MIKE. NO NEVER MIND. ALL RIGHT
SO THEN CAN WE MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
ONE PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE CONNECT US NOW WITH
SAMANTHA CORBIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION. MEMBERS THAT HAVE
A COMMON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION WE DO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT OF THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STOP LIMIT
THE NUMBER OF BILLS HEARD IN
THE COMMITTEE TO PROTECT THE
STATE DELEGATE REVENUE IF. WE
TEAR DOWN THE BARREL OF A
RECESSION JUST LAST WEEK OF
COURSE AND THEY REVISED WAS
RELEASED SIGNIFICANT CUTS TO A
VARIETY. OF HEALTH CARE
PRIORITY IS A PROGRAM. THAT
WILL PROPOSED. IDEA NOT
RIGHTFULLY NOTE THE STATE
FAILED THE NEW TAX BASE
PROFESSIONALLY SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE SOURCE THE STATE HAS
BEEN IN DECLINE FOR SOME TIME
NOW. A CALIFORNIA PURCHASE YOUR
ITEMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO P.
TRIED LOOKING MORTAR LOCATION-TO PURCHASE TANGIBLE PRODUCT.
VITAL THE NEW STORE IT'S ONLY
EXPECTED TO FURTHER DECLINE.
EXACTLY INCLUDING EXAM FACTOR
THAT. ARE INTENDED CHEN TO
INVENTED KEEP THAT WOULD NOT.
OCCUR GIVEN THE A NOR MODE. OF
BLOOD BANG TO PUT A PER. DUE
DILIGENCE AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS OF THE FAILURE TO
DO SO. WE BELIEVE IT'S UNLIKELY
THAT TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE
WILL RESULT IN ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD NOT OTHERWISE ALREADY
OCCUR BUT IN FACT ARE ACTUALLY
NECESSARY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. THE REALITY IS THAT
BLOOD CENTERS ARE ALREADY
RESPONSIBLE FOR PERFORMING A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THESE
TESTS FOR ITEMS SUCH AS THE
CLIFF HIV AND EVEN MORE
RECENTLY WEST NILE AND BEAKER
VIRUS WHICH WERE ADDED TO THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT. AS A FINAL
NOTE THE PROPONENT DID MENTION
AND THEIR TESTIMONY THAT THEY
BELIEVE THERE IS A DISPARITY
BETWEEN THE BLOOD BANK
ESTIMATED COSTS AND THE
POTENTIAL REVENUE IMPACT
PROVIDED BY THE STATE. TO THE
EXTENT THAT RELIEF IS TRULY
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THEM OF
CALIFORNIA'S LET BANKS AND
MEETING THE ADDITIONAL TESTING
DEMAND. THE TYPICALLY DO TO
COPE AT NINETEEN THE AUTHOR
MIGHT. CONSIDER A GRANT PROGRAM
NARROWLY TAILORED TO ENSURE
THAT NONPROFIT TESTING CAN
OCCUR AT THE SITE. THANK YOU.
IF THE MODERATOR WOULD NOW OPEN
LOAN MAINLINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION. GIVE
YOUR POSITION AS AN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. NO
LINES IN THIS Q. MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. BUT. SEVEN
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
A SPELL AND- I WOULD AGREE WITH
WITH YOUR ASSERTION THAT IT
DOES INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIORS ARE
THAT ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I
WOULD ARGUE FOR CALIFORNIA AT
ANY POINT IN TIME AND
PARTICULARLY NOW IN THE MIDST
OF THIS PANDEMIC SO VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT. TODAY THE DOCTOR
AND- CLOSING ONE ANOTHER WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A REVISED FISCAL
ESTIMATE FOR THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL IS
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN A
REVENUE LOSS OF THREE POINT ONE
MILLION. FOR YOUR TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY ONE AND SIX POINT TWO
ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO WITH
THAT SAID DR RANDALL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATION MISTER
RUFF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE HI BURKE FIVE BRO BRO
FIVE CHIU CHIU HI GRAY. LEVINE
LEVINE I MAYES. MULLIN I. HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I GLORIA.
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI
VOEPEL RIGHT. VOEPEL FIVE. THE
BILL HAS EIGHT BOATS THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM SIX
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
AB. TWENTY SEVEN NINETY NINE.
ADDITIONAL. DAVID DAVID MARK.
GREEN LIVING MARK. YEAH YEAH
YEAH. AND NEXT UP FILE ITEM TO
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF BAUER-KAHAN.
WELCOME PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE CHAIRWOMAN FOR HER
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS BILL- TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX THE KOBE
NINETEEN MAKE IS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE OF
EDUCATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACROSS THE NATION. ALMOST
OVERNIGHT SCHOOLS WERE CLOSED
AND CHILDREN WERE SENT HOME TO
LEARN REMOTELY BUT THERE ARE
FEW RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
STUDENTS WHO DIDN'T ON A LAPTOP
OR HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
THE PANDEMIC FURTHER
EXACERBATED AND HIGHLIGHTED THE
BASIC IN A QUALITY OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE EXPERIENCED BY
MANY STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ONE
IN FIVE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT TWO
BILLION IN FLAK BROADBAND OR
COMPUTER TAP BEST THERE THANK.
I'M SUPER. EARLY THIRTY FOUR OF
HOUSEHOLDS SUBSCRIBE TO
INTERNET COMPARED WITH SAID
EIGHT PER INNER AREAS. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ASSIST IN
BRIDGING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE BY
EXEMPTING PUBLIC SCHOOLS FROM
SALE STATE SALES TAX WHEN
PURCHASING CRITICAL QUITMAN
ASSOCIATED WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING SOME COULD LAPTOPS
TABLETS MOBILE HOT SPOT
SOFTWARE AND OTHER NECESSARY
TECHNOLOGY NEEDED TO ENSURE A
STUDENT IS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN DISTANCE LEARNING. THIS WILL
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MAKE
PURCHASES TO TRANSITION TO
DISTANCE LEARNING WITHOUT
PAYING THESE UP FRONT COSTS
THAT COULD OTHERWISE PREVENT
THEM FROM CLOSING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. LIGHT THE GOVERNOR'S
AND- WEEK IN HIS REVISED. THAT
WE COULD SEE A SUBSTANTIAL HIT
HER EDUCATION BUDGET. THIS BILL
COULD NOT BE TIMELIER. WE DO
NOT KNOW WHEN SCHOOL
INSTRUCTION WILL RESUME AS
NORMAL. ALTHOUGH IS A SCHOOL
PARENT I HOPE IT'S SOON.
HOWEVER WE NEED TO ACT NOW TO
ENSURE STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THEIR EDUCATION AND
THEY WANT TO FALL BEHIND. AB
TWENTY SIX CLOSE DIGITAL
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY AND
DEVICES PURCHASE FIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IT WILL ALLOW FOR
LEARNING IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ARE AMY MILLER AND
MEGHAN ROUSE FROM THE DOUBLING
UNIIED SCHOOL TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEIR DISTRICT
IS BASIC. WHAT THE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE MAINLINE TO
FOR- OUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. YOU MEAN MILLER YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY. DO I START
YES PLEASE. OKAY HI MY NAME'S
AMY MILLER AND I'M A SCHOOL
BOARD TRUSTEE AT THE DUBLIN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK ABOUT UPLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
EXPERIENCE WITH TRANSITIONING
TO DISTANCE LEARNING AND HOW
TIMELY AB TWO SIX THE FACT
THAT. OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
SERVED OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS THE FEAR
AND THAT NUMBER WILL JUMP
THIRTEEN THOUSAND NEXT YEAR
TWELVE SCHOOLS IN OUR SYSTEM
AND HAVE BEGUN CONSTRUCTION ON
A NEW HIGH CULTURAL COMPLETED
AROUND TWENTY BEFORE. I YOU CAN
THAT MAKE FORCED US IN A
DISTRICT IN THE STATE TO DANCE
TO TRANSITION TO REMOTE
LEARNING. ABOUT PROPER TIME TO
PLAN OR BUDGET WHICH REQUIRED
US TO RETOOL OUR STAFF OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR CLASSROOMS TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES. AND
REMAIN FOCUSED ON OUR MISSION
TO ENSURE EVERY STUDENT BECOMES
A LIFELONG LEARNER. SINCE APRIL
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
PURCHASED OVER SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED LAPTOPS AND PROVIDED
OVER SIXTY FIVE STUDENTS WITH
THE HOT SPOT. TO ENSURE THEY
STAY ON TRACK TO COMPLETE
COURSEWORK AND NOT FALL BEHIND.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGE FOR STAFF BUT WAS.
THE PART WELL. TOTAL WE SPENT.
OF TEN POINT FIVE. SO FAR ON
TECH. TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF
DISTANCE LEARNING IN OUR
DISTRICT. NOT ONLY IS THE UP
FRONT COST OF THESE ELECTRONIC
AND TECHNOLOGY EXPENSE THAT BUT
THE UPKEEP AND REPLACEMENT
COSTS WILL BE A CHALLENGE FOR
DISTRICT IN THE FUTURE. WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE PASSED BY
MEASURES HOWEVER WE HAVE NO
SHORTAGE OF FACILITY NEEDS
BEYOND. FOR A GROWING DIRECT.
OUR IS NOT UNIQUE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
FACING SIMILAR CHALLENGES. ANY
HELP WHEREVER WE CAN SURE OUR
STAFF AND STUDENTS ARE WELL
EQUIPPED WITH THE MATERIAL
THING NEED TO TEACH AND LEARN.
WE ALL KNOW THERE ARE MASSIVE
INEQUITIES ACROSS THE STATE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE ONLY SERVES TO
PERPETUATE- EIGHTY TWO SIXTY
SIX WILL HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THE BURDEN. ANYTHING THAT CAN
FINANCIAL ASSETS DISTRICTS
PROVIDE THE NEEDED LEARNING
MATERIALS FOR THEIR STUDENTS
IT'S A WIN WIN. ARE HAPPY
FOURTH. AND APPRECIATE YOU THIS
TIME WITH. OR LEGISLATION THAT
WILL PROVIDE ADEQUATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WAS VERY
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY WITNESS. HI
MEGHAN ROUSE SHOULD BE ON THE
LINE. FOR THE BEST. I DO NOT
HAVE OUTLINED CONNECTED ON
EIGHTEEN DECIDE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER PRO AND SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. I MODERATOR WE
OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR US
SUPPORT PLEASE. GIVE ME YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON THERE ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN IN YOUR
POSSESSION OF SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE UNKNOWNS ARE ALL. NO
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU AS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
BUT I CAN ALSO DO OUR POSITIONS
ARE ANY. IS A WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR ANY OPPOSITION. IF YOUR
POSITION IS IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY ALSO PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AGAIN THE COMMANDOS
WALKING ZERO IT WILL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. I AM SURE WE
HAVE A LINE OF MEGHAN ROUSE
LOCATED. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
OPEN IT YES PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. GO AHEAD.
I THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
MEGAN ROUTES AND I AM A TRUSTEE
WITH THE DUBLIN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND YOU'VE HEARD FROM
MY COLLEAGUE EIGHT TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX WILL PROVIDE RELIEF
WITH BELL AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT IT AS WELL AS A RESULT
OF THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
OUR NEED OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN GREAT. AB I THINK THAT.
LATE AND ANY REALLY TO ASSIST
THAT SHOULD AN OB THAT HOWEVER
THE REALITY IS DISTRICTS NAY
BROAD RELIEF ACROSS THE BOARD
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A PEAK OF
THAT RELIEF THAT IS REQUIRED IN
ORDER TO OPEN BOTH SAFELY MANY
ADDITIONAL ITEMS IN A QUICK.
I'M WE NEED FUNDS FOR THE-
MONEY AB TWENTY TWENTY THANK
BIRTHDAY BY CAN PROVIDE SOME OF
THE- NEEDED TO. MATH HAND
WASHING. THERMAL SCANNING CAN'T
CAMERA THAN TECHNOLOGY THE NAME
A FEW. IN ORDER TO OPEN SCHOOL
SAFELY WOULD HAPPEN I'M LOOKING
AT THE PLAN FOR OPEN CLOSE AND
HYBRID. I TEACHERS AND STAFF
HAVE WITH WITH MARK FLEX.
CREATIVITY AND HEART YOUR ROLE
IN OUR LEGISLATORS IS THAT THE
COURT THEIR EFFORT THE THREE
FACTORS MAINTAIN ITS JOURNEY
AND MOVE FORWARD. FOR ANY
ECONOMY ARE CONNECTED
STAKEHOLDER CRITICAL STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS NEED TO BE STATE
THAT CALL AND FAMILIES NEED TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE SENDING THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL. WE SHOULD BE
INVEST MORE IN AGE EDUCATION
FUNDING NOW AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REAP THAT AND MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY HEALTHY FOR STUDENTS
AND EDUCATION. TWENTY TWENTY
THANK. WE NEED AB TWENTY TWENTY
AM MORE DAMAGE OUR CORE
COMMITMENT OUR STATE AND THEIR
TEACHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I WILL JUST CHECK ONE MORE
TIME- THE WITH THE MODERATOR
JUST CONFIRM THAT THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION ONLINE. I HAVE A
LINE. OF THE COMMANDERS ONE
ZERO AND WE HAVE A LINE THIRTY
SEVEN ONE THIRTY SEVEN COULD
YOU STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION PLEASE. HI KATIE
HARD A MAN AT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THERE ARE
OTHERS PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. NO FOR THE LINE AND
YOU. I ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE. OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR YOU BECAUSE I JUST
WANT TO SAY A FEW WORDS- FIRST
THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO
WORK WITH US AND CURRENT
PANDEMIC IS HIGHLIGHTED IN AT
THE OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AS
MANY STUDENTS LACKEY CENTRAL
TOOLS. TO GET THEIR EDUCATION
REMOTE WITH TEACHERS AND
CLASSMATES. WELL OBVIOUSLY I AM
VERY. THE VICE IMPACT ON
CONTINUING CHILDREN'S EDUCATION
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS SHOULD REMAIN AMONG THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR CRITICAL
ISSUES. AS WE BALANCE COMPETING
PARTIES AND MAKE THE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK THAT WAS
MY CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU- DOCTOR MR ROUGHLY
THE WORLD. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROACH. BURKE I BURKE
I BRO. WROTE I JUNE. CHIU GRAY
LIVING LOW I NAY. MULLIN MORE I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
GLORIA. THREE OF US THREE OF US
I VOEPEL. VOEPEL HI. THAT HAS
EIGHT VOTES. THE BILL. AT THIS
POINT CHAIRS TAKE HER TO ITEMS
FILE ITEM THROUGH AB TWO SAID
AND FILA FOR AB SAY SIX ZERO
MADAM WHEN EVERY READY. ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON BY CHAIRMAN
SIMPLY TODAY TO PRESENT A
TWENTY FORTY SEVEN SIMPLE AND
TAX PAYER FRIENDLY FOR SPAHN BY
THE FOR TO BOARD THE F. T.
RECENTLY LEARN THAT THE IT
INTERN REMINISCE HAS STOP
ISSUING A RING FOR AND INDEED
TYPE IDENTIFICATION NUMBER OR I.
FOR NON RESIDENT DEPENDING
LIVING CANADA OR- THIS IS AN IN
CERTAIN CAL. TAX THE DEPENDENT
EXEMPTION CREDIT FOR THEIR
PRIZE QUAL NON READ TO PAY.
THIS IS THE CURRENT STATE LAW
REQUIRES A OR TO EITHER A SO TO
NUMBER OR ITIN FOR EACH TO FOR
THE CREDIT TO BE ALLOWED. AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN WHICH IS SPONSORED FIVE
FTV WOULD VERY SIMPLY GIVE
THESE TAXPAYERS THE OPTION OF
PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION FOR
PURPOSES OF CLAIMING THE
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION CREDIT.
WITH THAT I TURN THINGS OVER
THE FTV STAFF WHICH I
UNDERSTAND WILL BE TESTIFYING
REMOTELY TODAY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH A NET THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARDS LEGISLATIVE SERVICES
BUREAU. GET OUT LINE OF THE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME ARE AS YOU MENTIONED
CONNECTING THE AND I'M THE LEFT
JACK. FOR THE FRENCH TAX. ON A
LONG BASIS AT C. B. I CAN ALL
LIKE FOR LEAD FOR. BACK AT
LEAST MANY. INCLUDING THE ONE
FOR THE BEFORE TODAY. FIRST OUR
TO EXPRESS THEIR GRATITUDE
FUTURE FOR CAN THE- SO THAT
TAXPAYERS ABLE TO MEET THEIR TO
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION CRIED.
CURRENTLY AT THE MENTION
EXEMPTION THE FOR THOSE DEPEND.
THE SOCIAL NUMBER. AND
INDIVIDUAL. I NUMBEROFF
UNKNOWN THANK YOU. EVERYTHING
CHANGES THAT THE LAW FROM MAY
NO LONGER BE ABLE TO TEEN I FOR
THE DEPENDING. ELIGIBILITY
BEYOND WHAT IS CURRENTLY
EXISTING NOR DOES IT CHANGE
CHANGE THE CREDIT IN NOW BUT
MERELY ALLOW THE MECHANISM OF
THE NILE AND THE DEPENDENT
EXEMPTION CREDIT FOR THE
OTHERWISE QUALIFIED IN THE-
ADDITIONALLY TO ASSIST REQUIRED
MEET EXISTING. FOR THE CREDIT
FOR EXAMPLE THE SUPPORT ANOTHER
CHECK. BUT THE PROPOSAL WOULD
DELIVERY AT THE NUMBER REVENUE
AND TAXATION CAL TO ALLOW
TAXPAYERS AND ALTERNATE
BENEFITS FOR PROVIDING
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION. AFTER
THE LEGISLATIVE CHANGE FCB WILL
BE REQUIRED TO DENY THE
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION CREDIT FOR
OTHERWISE QUALIFIED DEPENDENT
BUT TREATING SIMILARLY SITUATED
TAXPAYERS DIFFERENT. STAFF
ESTIMATES THE COST TO IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENT THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
BE INSIGNIFICANT AND ABSORB THE
BALL. WE RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
AND AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AT THAT POINT I'M HAPPY TO HELP
WITH ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER IT'S A WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN
LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF THERE
ARE ANY. IF THERE IS SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN THERE ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. BLINDED YOU
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MODERATE WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPENTHE MAIN LINE IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. GIVE YOUR POSITION
AS OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONLINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CALL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. MADAM CHAIR WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE EXPECT THEIR
QUESTION ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISTER RUFF WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WE NEED A MOTION
AND A SIGN OF THE TO MOTION.
WILL MOVE ON THIS ISSUE. OUR
SECOND AT. MR OFFICE COMMOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE HI BURKE BY BRO HI BROKE
BY TWO. CHIU BY GREAT. LEVINE
LEVINE AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE
MULLIN MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS OUR GLORIA.
THREE OF US THREE OF US I WILL
TELL. VOEPEL NOW. THE BILL HAS
A FOLKS. OKAY WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR MEMBERS SAT ON THE CHAIR
SECOND BILL IS O FILE ITEM FOR
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY I'M SURE
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO ALSO
PRESENTED TO YOU TODAY AB
TWENTY SIX SIX GREW OUT OF A
PAPER. BY A MAN THE TIME
SECTION OF THE COW. C.
INTERNATIONAL EMPLOYEE OFF
TRAVEL TO. ON BUSINESS FOR
SHORT PERIODS OF TIME WHICH
GIVE RISE TO A PERSONAL INCOME
TAX OBLIGATION UNDER EXISTING
LAW. THESE BUSINESS TRAVELERS
HOWEVER ARE INELIGIBLE TO APPLY
FOR A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
WHICH REQUIRED FOR AN EMPLOYER
TO WITHHOLD AND REMIT TAXES BE
A PAYROLL. ADDITIONALLY ONLY A
VERY SMALL NUMBER OF THESE
FOREIGN EMPLOYEES FILE INCOME
TAX RETURNS ON AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS. BECAUSE OF THE TIMING
COMPLEXITY INVOLVED IN
OBTAINING AN- INDIVIDUAL TO
HEAR IDENTIFICATION NUMBER ITIN
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY PROPOSES A
NOVEL AND ENTIRELY VOLUNTARY
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL OFFERS
COMPANIES THE OPTION OF FILING
A GROUP RETURN AS A WAY TO
SIMPLIFY AND CAN I LINK TO THE
INTERNATIONAL. IN THIS WHAT
RIGHT IF CAN BENEFIT TO THE
COMMUNITY BY. TO COMPLIANCE AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS FOR BOTH
COMPANIES AND EMPLOYEES ALIKE.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO. LORRAINE CULLEN WITH
THE LATE WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT BY PHONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH LORRAINE
CONE OF DELIGHT TAX HELLO PETE.
MY NAME IS LORRAINE IN AND OUT.
OF THE TALKS PARTNER DELOITTE
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SIX SIX. I WAS
CHAIRMAN BURKE OUTLINE. UNDER
EXISTING CALIFORNIA LIVE
PLAYERS OF REQUIRED WITHHOLDING
ORDER ACTUALLY BE A PAYROLL
FOR. EMPLOYEES WHO PERFORM
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING NON US BUSINESS
TRAVELERS BUT THERE ARE UNABLE
TO DO SO. BECAUSE NOT REMIT
TAXES FOR PAYROLL IN NEEDS
FIRST I'M PAYING. A TAX NUMBER
I MENTION THE PREVIOUS BILL AND
CAL TAX. WE CALIFORNIA TIE
RETURN WHICH IS. WE BURDENS AND
COSTLY. FOR ALREADY STOPPED I
CAN'T EVEN OUTLINED THEM FOR
YOU TODAY BECAUSE WOULD NOT FIT
IN WITH. SIX MONTHS. HI ABLE TO
FILE TOLD CHARGES AND FINALLY
THE CALIFORNIA TAX RETURN LATE
WHICH WAS IN HEALTH FOR MY
FILING AND PUNITIVE TAX. SO HOW
MANY PEOPLE YOU THREE DEALING
LAST. THERE BE EASIER WAY. ALL
WOULD ALLOW A US COMPANY
STOPPED THE FINAL VOLUNTARY
BASIS. ARCHER TURNED OF PAYROLL
PORTING IN LITTLE SAMPLE AND
PAY I AND BY CALL INDIVIDUAL
RETURNS. THIS IS SIMILAR TO
KERN TOP LAWS THAT ALLOW
PARTNER A PARTNER. WITH YOUR-
THE- NOT ONLY WOULD BILL MAKE
IT ALL FOR COMPANY TO FILE THE
WAY EMPLOYEES ARE ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS KIDS IN THE
COMPOUND TAX. WELL IT WILL WIN
FOR EVER. IT WOULD ALLOW. TO
LIMIT WITH THE WAR ON A. TO DO
MINISTRY BURDENS ONE PULLING
THE AND GREATLY SAMPLE IT MAY.
AND FOR FROM PLAN. FOR I AM
VERY ON HOW TO COME WITH THE
TRAVEL ROLES. I GOT INTEREST
FROM COME TO COMPLY PLEASE. NO
ABLE TO THE SO SPECIAL. THANK
THANK YOU MISS COLLINS MODERATE
TO PLEASE UP THE MAIN LAW FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU ARE IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATE TO PLEASE HELP IN A
LINE IF THEY'RE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU YOUR
POSITION IS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN THAT QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU MOTOR WELL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
OR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NONE
BUT I'M SURE WOULD LIKE CLOSE
HAS BUTLER QUESTION I'VE A-
THANK YOU WE NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND. THREE OF US MOVES
MISTER MULLIN SECONDS THIS
ROUGH WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AND BURKE
HI BRO. BRO I CHIU. CHIU AYE
GRAY LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES
MAYES AYE MULLIN. MULLIN HI
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS ARE
AYE GLORIA THREE OF US
THREE OF US FIVE HOTEL. VOEPEL
I'D. THAT HAS NINE BUCKS. RAIN
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR WILL NOT
TAKE A FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COME ON UP WHEN
YOU'RE READY. CAN I UNDERSTAND
WE ALSO HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIVES IN HERE TO SPEAK ON THE
BILL IF YOU'D LIKE- I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO COME
UP I THINK YOU HAVE TO WAIT.
FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING PURPOSE
OF. ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. MANAGERS AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE- THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
THIS- BILL ALONG WITH MY JOINT
AUTHORED ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
GIPSON- ON AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT THE TIMELY WRITTEN
TAX ADVICE- CHAIR WOMEN BURKE I
WANT TO SINCERELY THANK YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION I
WANT TO SHARE WITH COMMITTEE.
THAT I'M AWARE THE TECHNICAL
CONCERNS- THAT WAS REYES AND IF
THIS BILL GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF TO ADDRESS
AND RESOLVE THESE CONCERNS- DUE
TO THE COVERT TEAM THAT MAKE
MANY OF THE TAXPAYER WILL
PRESENT. OUR FACING UNCHARTED
WATERS WHEN IT COMES. THE
JEWISH. FORTUNATE WITH THE
TERRORIST BILLS OF RIGHTS. AND
THE REVENUE AND TAXATION CODE
SECTION SIXTY FIVE NINETY SIX.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS TAXPAYERS
TO BE ABLE TO REQUEST BINDING
WRITTEN TAX ADVICE. THREE CIVIC
TO THEIR INCOME TAX OR SALES
AND USE TAX SITUATIONS AND
CURRENTLY ANY ADVICE THAT IS
PROVIDED VERBALLY IN PERSON OR
OVER THE PHONE IT'S CONSIDER IN
ALL AND NON BINDING THAT IS WHY
BINDING INVITE- BECAUSE
EXPOSURE OR RELIEVE OF TEXAS
PENALTY AND INTEREST EVEN IF
THE ADVICE IS BONUS AS LONG AS
A TAXPAYER FOLLOW THE RED.
ADVICE RECEIVE. HOWEVER THERE
HAVE BEEN INSTANCES WHERE
WRITTEN ADVICE WOULD TAKE YEARS
OR WHERE STATE- TAX DEPARTMENT
WOULD HAVE NO RECORD OF THE
WRITTEN ADVICE BEING REQUESTED
THIS CAUSES AN UNDUE HARDSHIP
ON TAXPAYER TRYING TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW IN GOOD FAITH IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
PENDANT AND PARTIAL OFFICE OF
ACCESS. FALCON ONE CASE WHERE
TAXPAYER ACTED IN GOOD FAITH
AND TOOK RESPONSIBLE IMPROPER
ACTION TO TIMELY COMPLY WITH
THEIR TAX OBLIGATIONS BUT THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD DID NOT
RESPOND TO THEIR REQUEST FOR
WRITTEN ADVICE UNFORTUNATELY
THE OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS FOUND
THAT AFTER TWO YEARS WELL
WRITTEN AND VOTE WAS RECEIVED
AT THE F. B. WASN'T TIGHTLY NOT
HELPFUL THEY CAME TO THE RECALL
RED AND VICE. EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
IT WILL BE A CERTAINTY AND
BETTER CUSTOMER SERVICE FOR THE
PAST WE REPRESENT THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE F. T. B. AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION TO
DO THINGS WITH EXPERT BUT
WRITTEN A VICE. LETTER TO
TAXPAYERS KNOWLEDGE IN WE SEE.
THE TAX RECALL. FOR WRITTEN IN
WITHIN THIRTY. AND PROVIDE THAT
BINDING AND READ ANDVICE
WITHIN A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS.
FROM THE DATE OF THE REQUEST
WAS RECEIVED. AND FINALLY
THERE'S A- OF. AS OF THIS
MOMENT WE HAVE NO NO OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT-
AND THE NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES. THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THIS BILL-
I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
AFTER REMEMBER GIPSON HAVE HAD
AS TO. MAKE HIS PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON THE BILL. MR OF WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER BREAUX ON A
SECOND BY PETRIE-NORRIS. THIS
TICKET SO WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO US A
MEMBER DEEPER RIPPING US.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT- I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FOR ONE OF HIS
FORESIGHT IN TERMS OF THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. IN ADDITION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP AND I OF
PERSONALLY HAVEEXPERIENCE
WORKING FOR- THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
THAT HAS NOW BECOME THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. THIS
COMMITTEE A WELL KNOW THAT
SALES TAX LAW CAN BEQUITE
COMPLICATED AND CONFUSING.
WHILE MOST BASIC QUESTIONS CAN
BE ANSWERED OVER THE PHONE IN
PERSON. FOR TAXES OR EVEN
THROUGH A TAX DEPARTMENT
WEBSITE BINDING WRITTEN ADVICE.
CAN BE REQUESTED SPECIFICALLY
TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
TAXPAYER BUT WHAT'S GOOD ABOUT
THAT IF IN FACT YOU CAN'T GET A
WRITTEN RESPONSE SOMETHING IN
WRITING AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS TO DO THIS BILL ASKED
BASICALLY FOR THE TYPE. OF
BOARD TO PROVIDE AND WRITING TO
TAXPAYERS AGAIN THIS WILL. CUT
DOWN ON AMBIGUITY I MISS
CONFUSION AND ALSO IN POWER THE
TAXPAYER TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND SO AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT IS A SIMPLE WELL I'M
HAPPY TO BE A CO AUTHOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AYE
UNDERSTAND WE PRIMARY
WITNESSES. WITH THE MOB PLEASE
CAN. IN WEATHER BE OF THE
CALIFORNIA TO. SAYS. AND
DOESN'T WANT TO BE IS NOT
CONNECTED AT THIS POINT. ALL
RIGHT AND MODERATOR IS THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESS PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT CONNECTED AT
THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME. RIGHT
CAN WE HOPE. CAN WE OPEN THE
MAINLAND JEREMIAH MALL OKAY
THEY ARE MADAM HAIRMAN ONLINE
OKAY I WASN'T AWARE OF MY LIFE-
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION MEMBERS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BILL HAD
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES SO I'M
JUST GOING TO ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
IS THERE AND ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF DUST
AND WEATHER BE CONNECTED NOW
THANK YOU. MR WEATHERBEE. THE
WEATHER HERE MY DAUGHTER I CAN
HEAR YOU NOW THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD SORRY ABOUT THAT WE HAVE
THAT WILL GET LO THESE. I'VE
NOT INSURED MEMBERS THINK MAYBE
DUSTIN WILL BE THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY. AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE ANTI TAX
BOARD INTO THE PFA TO RESPOND
TO READ AT A VICE REQUEST FROM
TAXPAYERS WITHIN A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS A RECEIPT BUT THE
RESPECTIVE AGENCY. UNDER
CURRENT STATE STATUTE THE VICE
PRINCIPAL PROVIDED TO A ACT
BERKALI WHETHER IN PERSON OR
OVER THE PHONE. INFORMAL AND
NON BINDING BEING THE TAXPAYER
NOT SOLELY RELY ON THE ACCURACY
THE FIGHTS RECEIVING AGENCIES
WHICH LEAD TO CONFUSION FROM
TAXPAYERS TO BELIEVE THEY WERE
ACTING JUSTLY BUT REACHING OUT.
IN THE FIRST PLACE ON THE OTHER
HAND WRITTEN BY BE RELIED ON
UPON IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS LINK
TO GREATER TAX. ON LIKE
TAXPAYERS RICK WRITTEN. THEIR
ACTING TO DATE TAKING HER STEPS
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE CALIFORNIA
COMPLICATED TAX LAWS. MAY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND TAXPAYERS
IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT AFFORD TO
HAVE A HIGHER TURN EVEN
ACCOUNTING STAFF TO HANDLE TAXI
CRICKET. CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
TIMETABLE FOR AGENCIES TO
RESPOND TO SUCH REQUESTS LEVY
TAXPAYERS A WINDOW INTO JANET.
SIMPLE INTEREST RECEIVE ADVICE
IN A TIMELY FASHION. CAL TECH
SELECT YOUR THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SPEAKING GIPSON FOR
CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
ITEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH
THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
MAIN LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU ARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KEVIN
TO DRIVE EIGHT REPRESENTING
NFIB IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND NOW FOR THE
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. AND IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND NOW OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
PLEASE CONTINUE THREE- COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CONTROLS. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE IT IS A
COMMON SENSE STEP WHICH ADDS
TRANSPARENCY AND IMPROVES THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE EXPERIENCE FOR
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS WOULD LOVE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR FEEL
HAPPY. BECAUSE. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SCENE NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVAL
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
MISTER OF CHOLERA. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE I BURKE BY BRO. WROTE I
CHIU Q. BY GRAY. GRAY FIVE
LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES- MAYES HI
MULLIN. MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
I THINK WE DID VETERAN OURS ARE
GLORIA. GLORIA HI THREE OF US
THE TRUTH FIVE HOTEL. VOEPEL
I'D. THE BILL ELEVEN VOTES THE
ELEVEN VOTES THAT ITEM IS OUT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
CONSENT ACCOUNT CAN CONSENT
CALENDAR. I HAVE A MOTION BY
BROE'S SECOND BY GLORIA. AND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS MADE
WITH FILE ITEM SEVEN AB THIRTY
THREE SEVENTY TWO AND FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY
THREE. MISTER RUFF WE YOU.
BURKE I BURKE FIBRO BRO I CHIU.
ISSUE I LEVINE. LEVINE I GRAY
GRAY I MAYES MAYES HI MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARE GLORIA.
GLORIA HI THREE OF US
THREE OF US FIVE HOTEL. HOTEL
FIVE. THE BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
THE CONTENT KAREN PASSES NOW
MOVE TO THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS-
WILL FIRST ITEM WILL TAKE IS
FILE ITEM NINE AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY SELLING MOMENT
IRWIN I HAVE A MOTION BY BROKE
AND A SECOND BY PIT.
PETRIE-NORRIS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS MISTER
ROUGHLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE HI BURKE AYE BRO. BRO I
TO WRITE TO OUR GRAY GREAT I
LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES. MAYES I
MULLIN MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS OUR GLORIA GLORIA
I THREE OF US THREE OF US AYE
VOEPEL BY. WELL I. THAT HAS
ELEVEN VOTES THAT I DIDN'T
HOUSES THE SECOND VOTE ONLY
ITEM IS FILE ITEM TEN AB TWENTY
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER PEROT AS SECOND BY
GLORIA MR ROUGHLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI. BURKE
FIVE BRO. WROTE I CHU. CHU AYE
GRAY. RAY I LEVINE LEVINE HI
MAYES MAYES AYE MULLIN. ONE I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS ARE
GLORIA. GLORIA I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US FIVE HOTEL I WE'LL
TELL FIVE. HAS ELEVEN VOTES NOT
ITEM HOUSES I WILL NOW CALL THE
BILLS FOR ABSENTEE MEMBERS FILE
ITEM ONE AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE. MISTER RUFF PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENTEES. RIGHT RIGHT I
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE. GLORIA.
GLORIA BY. THE BILL HAS ELEVEN
VOTES SENATE BILL PASSES WITH
ELEVEN VOTES FILE ITEM TO AB.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX MR
ROUGHLY PLEASE CALL ABSENTEE
MEMBERS. GREAT GREAT. MAYES MAY
SORRY. GLORIA GLORIA HI. THE
BILL AS TEN VOTES ON THAT FINAL
PAT NINE PASSES WITH TEN VOTES
FILE ITEM THREE AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN BURKE MR ROUGHLY
CALL THE ABSENTEES. RIGHT RIGHT
HI. LORIA. GLORIA HI HOW ARE
YOU. TEN TO ONE. AT I AM PASSES
TEND TO ONE MOVING FILE ITEM
FOR AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY BURKE
MR OF WE CALL THE ABSENTEE
VOTE. MEMBERS GREAT. GREAT I.
GLORIA GLORIA HI. THE BILL HAS
ELEVEN VOTES THE BILL PASSES
WITH ELEVEN VOTES FILE ITEM
FIVE AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT MISTER IF WE CALL THE
ABSENTEE MEMBERS. NO ABSENTEES
ON THAT ITEM. LIVING FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB THIRTY THREE SEVENTY
TWO. AS A CONSENT ITEM. LET'S
GO TO THE VOTE ONLY ITEMS. FILE
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY THIRTEEN.
NO ABSENTEES ON THAT ITEM FREE
AND FILE AND TEN AB TWENTY
FIFTY EIGHT. NO ABSENTEEISM
ITEM. WITH THAT I THINK THE
MODERATOR AND THE STAFF HERE IN
THE BUILDING FOR TODAY'S
HEARING AND WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED.